[Música]
una tierra con reputación de ser salvaje
con un bosque virgen como marco
incomparable
del otro lado del atlántico la guayana
francesa es una de las joyas más bellas
del país
una naturaleza rebosante una fauna
exuberante
pero hoy en día la amenaza acecha esta
biodiversidad sin igual tierra y mi
lápiz y mike wilson entomólogos
su trabajo consiste en identificar las
diferentes especies de insectos para
protegerles mejores
ai ai ai
lo viste así se fue por ahí
ahí está
es un long y corn you poco usual de la
familia de los emmy love in entonces te
transmito esto a la especialista creo
que estará muy contento por este bosque
exuberante contiene muchos tesoros
plantas con poderes increíbles que
también hay que conservar
frank y joanes sanador transmite su
conocimiento a las jóvenes generaciones
para sensibilizar las mejoras
no le hace daño con todos los golpes que
le da cicatrizar a
de aquí un año habrá recubierto todo y
no morirá en la cultura a melilla el
bosque sagrado el bosque de hecho es
nuestra madre lo que nos alimenta no hay
que destruirlo
[Música]
y conservar el bosque a cualquier precio
es el mensaje que el sanador trata de
transmitirles a los turistas que visitan
su pueblo comparte parte de su
conocimiento con ellos
limpiará la sangre si tiene problemas de
hígado por ejemplo dos de estos es como
un doctor
y si me gusta todo lo medicina y si
además permite no acudir a otros
productos químicos y más bien volcarse a
lo que la naturaleza nos provee
en la guayana francesa no solo el bosque
está amenazado
en las costas las tortugas marinas
podrían desaparecer
también chevalier es investigador en el
cnt se realiza también contamos con la
cámara embarcada
estamos listo mismo
con su colega tratan de entender este
fenómeno
recorren una playa durante toda la noche
entendido
la luz es la tortuga marina más grande
entre junio y agosto hace su nido en las
costas de la guayana francesa hay un
hueco en su aleta posterior puede haber
sido por anzuelos que se agarran y que
arrancan un poco del tejido la tortuga
luz está en declive el primer factor
sería la pesca accidental también está
la erosión que destruye el 40% de los
nidos cada año ello explica que no
tengamos una renovación de población
para entender lo que genera la extinción
de las tortugas marinas hay que hacerle
seguimiento
el investigador instala una cámara en su
espalda
hace 30 años había unas 50 mil al año en
la guayana francesa
hoy en día no hay más de 200
[Música]
durante la noche los entomólogos también
salen
están llegando las primeras mariposas
acaban de poner su trampa y la sábana
blanca está llena de insectos de todo
tipo en una noche podemos observar una
enorme diversidad de insectos hay
mariposas saltamontes a veces libélulas
así que todos los insectos que hay en el
bosque
me están conquistando
más allá de los insectos el bosque de la
guayana francesa está lleno de otras
especies que se pueden ver fácilmente en
la noche
como esta pequeña rana y la medusa tomo
terna
es la familia de las filo medusas ranas
arbóreas
es una de las especies más bellas que se
encuentran aquí está en peligro hay una
gran deforestación en la amazonía su
hábitat está desapareciendo y ella
también
en la medida en que están protegidas la
captura de estas ranas está prohibida
así como cortar tortugas luz
en la mañana damien recorre los primeros
datos transmitidos por las balizas
instaladas el día anterior
esta es una tortuga que dentro de unas
horas estará tal vez a 10 kilómetros de
su lugar de puesta y que se desplazará a
cientos de kilómetros lo que queremos
saber es a dónde va este individuo dónde
se alimenta dónde descansa
[Música]
la cámara también entrega sus primeros
tesoros
[Música]
imágenes increíbles que permitirán
conocer mejor esta especie en peligro